breaking news alert
and that breaking news right now at six
o'clock heavy police presence near the
95 in the area of charleston as you can
see there on the right hand side of your
screen lots of
police cruisers there traffic is a mess
in that area the i-team's david charns
is live with what's going on dave
denise and brian we're just learning
that a suspect is dead in a police
involved shooting here near the u.s 95
in charleston traffic is a mess it took
us quite a while to get here so just
stay away if you can but if i step out
of the way you can see police are
investigating here near this pollo loco
which is on charleston right near those
ramps to get on and off the 95 traffic
backed up there though here on
charleston for about a quarter mile or
so there is no traffic all roads on and
off the road here are closed police
focusing in on an apartment complex
behind this restaurant and as we got
here several witnesses came up to us
asking what was going on they said that
they had to evacuate those apartment
complexes some of them told to stay in
they they left and right now they can't
go inside it's sort of a lockdown
situation right now though we have
learned that the suspect in this officer
involved shooting has died now the
interesting thing about all this is
we're seeing a lot of henderson police
in the area here henderson police are
investigating this officer
officer-involved shooting we understand
it was a henderson police officer but we
are in metro territory so we're working
to get information on that but a big
police presence here on charleston near
the 95 can't get on or off the highway
there and traffic backed up both on
charleston sahara and lamb so if you're
in that area you know someone who will
be want to give them a warning to just
avoid this area bring you updates
throughout the night i'm david charns
near charleston and lamb tonight live
local now